oh god here he comes how's the thing on
your arm going look at that
oh not too good does it look worse did
you go to the doctor
oh my god it's bleeding did you go to a
doctor
yeah but uh i didn't get to go see him
again oh what did he say it is
they the test got to come back i got to
call him today it was almost all gone
now i know do you think it's because
you're covering it uh
i don't know i went swimming this
weekend did you change the bandage
yeah dude like his skin is getting ready
that can be very contagious
i want him out of here yeah me too go to
a doctor
you should be at the emergency room yeah
go to emergency room i got to know what
that is i can't let you around all these
people you could be spreading that
yeah yeah well i didn't want to call in
and make you guys think i was faking it
dude look at that thing just go to a
hospital and i'm telling you that looks
highly contagious
can you can you cover it sorry uh
honestly i'll get out of here
robin you agree that doesn't look right
that's frightening compared to where it
was
that's frightening that it's getting
like that i see it richard close it up
yeah you agree with me right yeah
what's crazy what's all that crap all
over the bandage too uh just leakage i
guess
it was what a mosquito bite uh purple
yeah
fred hold the door from so he doesn't
touch that i don't want to touch the
door i'll use my t-shirt
all right use your jacket okay on the
other side touch the door open no no no
no
you push the door open all right and
burn those headphones
yeah oh no where's your where's your
bandage
it cleared up because you took the
bandage off no it was fake
oh it was terrible you've been richard
christie
get out of here it's just stupid but but
by the way it hasn't cleared up
that was all special effects makeup my
buddy brian doesn't look that much
better
go to the hospital you've been howard
stern go to the hospital now leave
you're fired don't ever prank me again
no don't waste my time sorry and p.s
your [ __ ] arm still looks infected to
me so i don't even know who you're
pranking
the joke's on us we're going to be sick
but it's gotten much better though
better than what it's still infected
look at that [ __ ] thing it should
have cleared up by now it's been weeks
i mean what you're richard christian
but the fact of the matter is your arm's
still infected
but it's not that bad it's not as bad as
the thing you just presented with your
friend's makeup but it's still bad
and if i was your friend i'd go get
myself checked out if you could still be
covered you shouldn't be playing games
with it
i still think it looks horrible i don't
know it's not completely healed
leave and he's playing with it i'm sorry
howard no you don't understand what i'm
saying
i know you're saying you're making
pranks but you're sick
but yeah you're still worried yeah that
doesn't look good to me
goodbye okay sorry
you really are disgusting
you're disgusting the joke is you hired
this nutcase
now i'm going to die from him
because you've been richard christie
you've been christie
i've been no i haven't you're disgusting
you've been stearned what is that that's
where you don't have a job
[ __ ]
you